particular in the case that we get the likely outcome zero the state becomes the squ otk of p 0 * row * theun of p 0
all normalized so that we get a density Matrix and what the gentle measurement limit tells us is that in this event
meaning that we do indeed get the likely measurement outcome the state we obtain will not have changed very much from the
original and in particular the Fidelity squared will necessarily be larger than 1 minus
Epsilon and this is great because this is completely General we haven't said anything at all about the measurement or
the state except that one of the outcomes is very likely so the Lemma can be applied in
many different settings where we'd like to verify something about a Quantum State without disturbing it very much so let's see how we can prove
it and for the most part it's actually a pretty simple matter of calculating the Fidelity between the pre and postmeasurement
States we can do this by using the original definition and ordinarily that might leave us with a messy formula but
in this case we luck out because the thing inside of the outer square root is actually the square of a matrix that
happens to be positive semi-definite which makes Computing the square trivial we can now use the cyclic
property of the trace along with the linearity of the trace to simplify our expression as it shown on the screen notice by the way that these are
all equalities so we haven't approximated anything at this point we're really just simplifying but now we do need an
inequality because we'd like to get rid of that square root in the numerator and we can indeed do that if we're willing to settle for a lower bound and if
you're interested in the details for this part you can get the inequality pretty easily by considering a spectral decomposition of p
0 the IG values of p 0 have to be between 0 and one that's always true for matrices that describe
measurements and once we know that the inequality follows pretty directly from the fact that taking the square root of
a number between 0o and one can only make it larger another way to say that is that squaring a number between Z and
one can only make it smaller we can now simplify just a little bit more and we we get the square
root of the trace of p 0 * row finally squaring both sides and
plugging in our bound on the probability gives us what we want so the formula for the Fidelity
isn't the nicest or easiest to use formula in the world but here it actually works pretty
nicely to conclude the lesson we'll take a look at alman's theorem which is a fundamental fact about the Fidelity that
connects it with the notion of a purification what the theorem says in simple terms is that the Fidelity between any two
Quantum States is equal to the maximum inner product in absolute value between two purifications of those
States in a bit more detail suppose that row and sigma are density matrices for some system X and suppose that Y is a
system that has at least as many classical States as X and therefore we're guaranteed that both of these states have purifications that are
quantum State vectors of XY we can then Express the implication of the theorem in the form of the equation
shown on the screen the Fidelity between row and sigma is equal to the maximum absolute value of the inner product
between F and SII ranging over all fi and S that purify row and sigma
respectively so let's clean this up and work with the precise mathematical statement going forward what we'll do now is to prove
the theorem but first it's worth taking a moment to appreciate that it offers us a pretty intuitive way of thinking about the
Fidelity it also happens to be quite useful in its own right for instance to prove even more interesting things about
the Fidelity to prove it we'll start with spectral decompositions of our density
matrices no surprises there once we have spectral decompositions it's easy to come up with
two specific purifications of these states but here we're actually going to play a
trick notice that in both cases we don't have a standard basis VOR as the second tensor Factor like we did earlier in the
lesson but rather we have the same Vector as in the first tensor Factor except that it has a bar over it and
that means the entry-wise complex conjugate of these vectors so in other words we're basically just taking a
second copy of the igen vectors but we take the complex conjugate of each entry and we'll see why we do that in a few
moments but it's not at all obvious that we should do this and that's why we call it a
trick in any case these are purifications of row and sigma respectively and that's true by virtue
of the fact that our igen vectors are orthonormal and therefore so are their entry-wise complex conjugates and now we can apply the
unitary equivalence of purifications which says that every purification of our two states can be obtained by
applying a unitary operation to the system that gets traced out for the specific choices of purifications that
we just made the unitary operations don't have to be the same for the two purifications
of course so here we're using the letter U for the first one and the letter V for the second
one so the point is that every purification of our two states can be written as we have on the screen for
some choice of unitary operations u and v and now we can take the expression
from the theorem and simplify if we plug in our expressions for F and S and simplify a little bit we
get the expression that's shown here on the screen now there are a couple of steps in there and I haven't shown the details
so you know what to do if you want to do it but let me mention that the reason why we chose the purifications as we did
was to allow this inner product to simplify in exactly this way and in particular we put the complex conjugates
in there so we'd effectively be able to flip around the inner products in the second tensor factor to get the specific
form that we have right here we're almost there now we can use the cyclic property of the trace along
with the spectral decompositions we started with to get this expression and at this point we can
employ one of the alternative ways of expressing the Fidelity using the trace norm and we're
done certainly there are details in there that I glossed over very quickly and it's the kind of proof that you
really do need to work through yourself to fully grasp but hopefully this gives you the basic
idea and as usual you can find more details in the written content for the lesson which is linked in the video
description and that's the end of the lesson which has been about purifications Fidelity and the connections between them and it's also